[Music]
how are you guys doing everyone's been
very active very passionate uh and very
enthused about doing good work for
Palestine taking the pro Palestine
position going online doing the charity
work now which has been made available
to us Etc but there's another country
where in which you'll find atrocities
being uh committed and that is Sudan a a
big Muslim country both geographically
and by population in uh Africa uh and
this really is something which has been
under reported I think we haven't spoken
about this enough guys I mean to be
honest with you what's happened if we
know the history of this country and
what's happened especially with the rsf
forces uh recently the rapes that have
been committed or the sexual assaults on
mass have been committed the
displacement the major displacements
Happening by the rsf and the these other
groups of mercenaries coming from
outside of the country uh many of the
things that we're seeing in fact Al
jazer has um videos of of this group The
rsf in Sudan killing civilians um you
can actually watch those V Al or Arabic
I mean so this is something which
requires we need to be aware of what's
going on in Sudan because it's it's
absolutely disgusting and we can apply
pressure just in much as much in the
same way as we're doing with Palestine
on what's happening in in in uh sud then
so this is this is actually you know
it's um very disappointing because uh I
haven't come across anything about this
even scrolling and stuff like that and
um yeah this I think will be very
important for us to know because you you
described this as uh potentially another
genocide going on and for us not to know
about this is uh I mean um well so what
it is is let's let's break this down uh
Sudan is a country she's been
independent since 1956 okay and um ever
since that time has had as as as much of
Africa much of the Middle East and much
of the world in fact what you refer to
as authoritarian rule okay so you have a
strong dictatorial type uh president or
prime minister thus in charge of the
country dictator let's just call him for
the sake of argument and uh recently the
most notable thing that's happened is
you had this guy called Basher okay now
he was in charge of the country uh until
fairly recently and uh one of the main
things that has happened is in the year
2000 where probably the most numbers of
civilians had been killed through a
military coup so this this other group
which came out uh by which we'll talk
about in a second but they came out and
they tried to resist against Bashir they
came out this led to the killing of some
say by the way hundreds of thousands of
people not even tens of thousands
honestly but not in a short space of
time so with the Palestine issue as you
guys know like it's it's only been 3
months and we've got 30,000 people so
the these like the guardian for example
you take this um these figures with a
pinch of salt having said that the
official numbers of the government is
much less they say only 10,000 people
were killed which is nonsense impossible
um is that with with over a 5year period
within a 5-year period uh from the year
2000 onwards that about 300,000 people
died now that's that might be skewed
numbers or whatever it may be but that's
still in three in um in that much time 5
years 300,000 people if if it's even
close to being true let's say 100,000
people that's still a massacre at a high
high uh level and we've got we've got
the killing of the people civilians we
have we have the displacement of the
people and then we have especially this
tactic which is is um particular ularly
pernicious which seems to be ongoing and
it seems to be one of the things they do
on mass they sexually assault women in
all kinds of different ways we're
talking about the rsf here and this is a
a kind of like a in the beginning so
what happened with the rsf is who are
the rsf you had this you had this guy
called hamti okay and this individual he
was kind of like the leader of this
group um he was part of this Splinter
Group who was a par paramilitary group
or militia group what you call it what
you want to call it in the last couple
of years maybe 2021 onwards 2020 they
were offered a power sharing agreement
so they were offered to be subsumed
within the Sudanese armed forces that so
in other words because of you know the
coups that happened in the
past a way to resolve this issue was to
bring um this particular group within
the uh the framework of the government
and so so what happened recently so why
is this happening again now so we've
spoken about from 1956 all the way to
2000 and from 2000 all the way to
2021 uh what's happening in recently is
that in in um 2021 2022 that they
violated the the peace um sharing the
power sharing agreement and they went
back into a state of War so effectively
what you have now in Sudan is you
effectively have another civil war you
have another civil war you've got hamti
on the one hand of the rsf and you have
the Sudanese Army and these guys are you
know the rsf are committing the most
atrocities they are committing the most
atrocities they're getting people from
outside we can see these atrocities and
they are narrated on mass uh Mass
transmitted by people all over we have
videos like in Al jaer as I mentioned Al
Arc is probably the best source to see
people being killed in women testimony
uh doing testimonials on on how they've
been sexually assaulted Etc uh recently
uh even more recently so you've had as
we've mentioned we talked about from
1956 all the way to 2000 2000 all the
way to 2020 2021 and now we're in
2023 so the The Last Bow of um kind of
uh issues has been in August
2023 where the up you know the the the
tensions have risen
again and we were talking about when we
talk about displacement here we're
talking about displacement of millions
of people m we're not talking about
displacements of tens of thousands or
hundreds we're talking about
displacements some say three some say 5
million there's all kinds of estimates
but people have to to leave the main
areas so we're talking about for example
the capital of Sudan and other areas
they have to leave uh those areas
they're displaced It's actually an
atrocity and it's only fair that this
needs to be covered people need to be
first of all with this issue number one
informed of what's
happening and the same basic strategy
that we are applying with Palestine we
need to apply with
Sudan um in as much the same way we have
concern with the Palestinian people we
have to be concerned with the Sudanese
people and and this was the first of
many videos obviously with critical
content news um mus has done a range of
videos on this we've have a range of
Articles being written on the website as
well if people want to see and have more
information on that maybe I'll put them
in the description box in the in the
comment section Tarak kurd has you know
T he's he's a fantastic job writing that
some really brilliant articles on this
as well I think we the first are there
any donation links that people can we
need to look at we're still in the
process of looking at which is what are
the best Charities what at this point in
time I think the first step is to know
what's going on and to get people both
intellectually and emotionally invested
with this issue because we can't you
know have um a skewed relationship with
the the um is the um so one Sudanese
person dying is the same as one
Palestinian person dying 100% you know
you know there's absolutely no
difference whatsoever and I hope
everyone here has taken heed of this
video and understands now what's
happening in
Sudan yeah just just I don't know to me
personally I I have no it was it was
news to me when you came and told me I
know something was happened in Ethiopia
I was thinking then Sudan I had no idea
so to me it just shows like I haven't
heard of it anywhere I'm not on Twitter
not on Instagram I haven't heard of it
anywhere I don't know why not uh which
again brother and sisters we shouldn't
treat the of Gaza becomes a fashion
sometimes yes there are people who
genuinely care but it becomes something
that kind of a fashion thing you know
it's really important for us to check
our intentions because if you don't feel
the same way about the plight of the San
or wherever for that matter we really
need to question our heart uh to me like
I said I had no idea I'm going to try my
best to look into it even more and try
to raise awareness to it um and like I
said if few Brothers can inform me if
there's a charity that we can raise
towards that on the ground whatever for
that matter but from the this moment on
was going forward it's important for us
to do our research uh and uh put as much
effort as we can as as much as we are
with the Gaza situation to see what's
going on cuz over there you're talking
four or five million people displaced uh
thousands of people being killed so yes
I think we should put the same thing and
also SJ news in I'm sure Zan's going to
look into as well so yeah definitely we
should renew our intentions and make
sure that you know we are morally
consistent whoever it is been done
doesn't matter the color for that
matter